في اخر اجتماعي لهم هذا العام الذي يسعون
فيه قدر الامكان لاظهار الوحده في وجه
روسيا تفرق خلافات عده قاده الاتحاد
الاوروبي اخفق وزراء الطاقه قبيل القمه في
التواصل الى اجماع بشان وضع سقف لاسعار
الغاز ترفض دور على راسها المانيا هذا
السقف خوفا من توجه المنتجين الى اسواق
اخرى قدمت المفوضيه الاوروبيه اقتراحا
اعتبرت الدول المطالبه بوضع هذا السقف انه
يتضمن شروط صارمه هدفها الا يطبق على
الاطلاق رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شال ميشيل
قال انه وضع سقفي لاسعار الغاز امر المعقد
وتحدي كبير لكنه عبر عن ثقته بالقدره على
التوصل الى اتفاق تستمر هذه الخلافات في
وقت يشدد فيه الرئيس الاوكراني في قمه
القاده الاوروبيين على اهميه حرب الغاز
ستكون الاشهر السته المقبله حاسمه من
نواحي عديده في المواجهه التي بداتها
روسيا بهذا العدوان العدوان على اوكرانيا
وضد ده كل واحد منكم لان الهدف النهائي
لروسيا هو ابعد بكثير من حدودنا والسياده
الاوكرانيه اولا يجب هزيمه ارهاب الطاقه
الروسي بجميع اشكالها وثانيا صمود
اوكرانيا في هذا الشتاء
ليس سقف اثار الغاز الخلافه الوحيده بين
الاوروبيين فقد عطلت بولندا حزمه مساعدات
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 18 مليار يورو كما عطلت
الاتفاق على الحسمه التاسعه من العقوبات
على روسيا بسبب خلاف بشان قائمه الاسماء
التي ستطعلها العقوبات لا شك ان هذه
الخلافات تلقى صدا ايجابيا في روسيا التي
ماتت تندد بما تعتبره حربا اقتصاديه غربيه
عليه
روسيا كان يهدف بشكل اساسي الى تحقيق
اقتصادنا في وقت قصير وتدمير العمله
الوطنيه من خلال سرقه احتياطياتنا من
العملات الاجنبيه واحداث ضخم المدمر هذه
الحسابات كما رايتم ونرى جميعا لم تفلح
يعول الاوروبيون على ان تؤدي الحرب
الاقتصاديه التي يتحدث عنها بوتن الى جعل
روسيا غير قادره على مواصله الحرب
العسكريه في اوكرانيا لكن الخلافات بين
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي والخلافات بين دول
الاتحاد والولايات المتحده ربما تعرقل
خططهم جميعا فالقاده الاوروبيون يناقشون
في قمهم ايضا العلاقات مع الولايات
المتحده والاجراءات التي اتخذتها الاداره
الامريكيه لحمايه اقتصادها والتي تضر
بالشركات الاوروبيه انها خلافات تشوش حتى
الان على الرغبه في اظهار الوحده للدروسيا